Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断为你工作的收入，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details.
这些原则都对你适用。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。
Right, let's get on with today's episode. Is there ever a wrong time to pursue your professional career in psychology or to advance it beyond its current state? That is the question. There could be a variety of reasons why you or others around you might be telling you that it could be the wrong time. And today we are taking a closer look at that with personal insight and reflections from my guest. It's a wonderfully powerful, evocative episode. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. As I said in the intro, we are
好了，让我们继续今天的节目。追求心理学职业生涯，或者将其推进到当前阶段之外，是否存在所谓的“错误时机”？这就是问题所在。你或你周围的人可能会出于各种原因告诉你，这可能是一个错误的时机。今天，我们将通过我的嘉宾的个人见解和反思来仔细探讨这个问题。这是一个非常强大、引人共鸣的节目。希望你能觉得它很有用。嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。正如我在引言中所说，我们正在
looking at whether there is ever such a thing as a wrong time to pursue your career in psychology or to progress it beyond where you are currently. And we are talking with Jasmine Thompson, who lost her mum within the last 12 months. And it is a really, really special episode. I cry, she cries. We do talk about grief quite openly and how it's affected us and our practice. And I hope you can look after yourself if you are struggling right now. If this does feel a little bit too raw, you might choose to watch or listen at a later stage. But it feels like a really important conversation to have
探讨追求心理学职业生涯或将其推进到当前阶段之外是否存在所谓的错误时机。我们正在与贾斯敏·汤普森（Jasmine Thompson）对话，她的母亲在过去12个月内去世了。这是一个非常非常特别的节目。我哭了，她也哭了。我们非常坦诚地讨论了悲伤，以及它如何影响了我们和我们的实践。如果你现在正在苦苦挣扎，我希望你能照顾好自己。如果这让你觉得有点太直白、太沉重，你也可以选择在以后观看或收听。但这似乎是一次非常重要的对话，
and so I hope you do find it useful even if you are not currently grieving I think it will help you to really develop some insight some understanding to what people you might be working with might be experiencing and maybe to think about you know this being a useful episode for if things happen in future i would love to know what you think to the episode do please come and connect with me on social media where i'm dr marianne trent everywhere and also come and join the free facebook group the aspiring psychologist community with dr marianne trent but yeah please look after yourself i hope you find this a really helpful episode and i'll look forward to catching up with sharing psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent. But yeah, please look after yourself. I hope you find this a really helpful episode and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the
所以我希望你能觉得它有用，即使你目前并没有经历悲伤。我认为这会帮助你真正培养一些洞察力、一些对你可能共事的人所经历的事情的理解，也许还可以让你思考，你知道的，这对于未来如果发生某些事情时会是一个有用的节目。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法，请务必在社交媒体上与我联系，我到处都是 Dr Marianne Trent，也欢迎加入由玛丽安·特伦特博士带领的免费 Facebook 群组“有抱负的心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community）。但是，是的，请照顾好自己。希望你觉得这是一期非常实用的节目，我期待在另一端与你交流。（注：原文此处有重复的口播内容，按规则原样保留翻译）
other side. Hi, just want to welcome along our guest for today, Jasmine Thompson. Hi, Jazz. Hi, how are you? I'm okay, thank you. Thanks for asking. How are you? Good, yeah, I'm good, thank you we were just talking about how it feels to be calling yourself an incoming trainee clinical psychologist because as we record it's the summer but when this episode goes live you're going to be days away from having that lanyard around your neck that actually says trainee clinical psychologist so how is that feeling for you? It's just crazy hearing you say that and knowing you know yeah in a few months I'll be starting it's been such a long time coming and and you know everyone knows it's a bit of a relentless process well it can be for me it was quite challenging so for it to be actually I'm there and as you said seeing my name with
嗨，我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾贾斯敏·汤普森。嗨，爵士。嗨，你好吗？我很好，谢谢。谢谢你问。你好吗？很好，是的，我很好，谢谢。我们刚才还在谈论自称“准临床心理学实习生”是什么感觉，因为在我们录制时正值夏天，但当这期节目上线时，你距离脖子上挂着印有“临床心理学实习生”字样的挂绳只有几天时间了，所以你感觉怎么样？听到你这么说真是太疯狂了，而且我知道，是的，几个月后我就要开始了。这一天等了太久了，每个人都知道这是一个相当残酷的过程——好吧，对它来说确实如此。对我和我而言，这是相当具有挑战性的。所以当这一切真正实现时，正如你所说，看到我的名字和
incoming trainee clinical psychologist is just it's surreal but very grateful very excited. Oh well well done to you because you know I know they do not give these golden tickets away lightly or easily so it's absolutely well earned but you know the reason for us talking today is that there's a very special someone who you would have dearly loved to have been able to say and they weren't there were they do you want to tell us a little bit about about what I'm talking about Jazz? Yeah absolutely and I think those watching my eyes will go a bit glossy but it happens um but my lovely mum sadly died a year ago um almost a day so in um July last year in 2023 um she had cancer she first was diagnosed when I was actually 12, so around 15 years ago.
“准临床心理学实习生”连在一起，感觉太超现实了，但我非常感激，也非常兴奋。哦，那真是恭喜你了，因为我知道他们绝不会轻易把这些“金门票”送人，所以这是你应得的。但是，我们今天谈话的原因是，有一个非常特别的人，你本非常渴望能把这个好消息告诉她，但她却不在了，对吗？你想跟我们聊聊我正在说的事情吗，爵士？好的，完全可以。我想看我节目的观众可能会看到我的眼睛有点湿润，但这是难免的。嗯……我慈爱的妈妈不幸在一年去世了——差不多正好是一年前的今天。所以是在2023年7月……她患有癌症。她最初被诊断出患病时，我其实才12岁，也就是大约15年前。
And it was always kind of in the background. But my mum was amazing because she never made it a huge part of our lives. She was amazing. She'd work through, she ran her own companies. So she worked through all her treatments. And it was always something that was happening in the background that didn't hugely impact us. I think we were always very positive about the treatment she was getting but sadly a year ago she did have a terminal diagnosis. She got a brain tumour which was unable to be treated. We found out about that around
它一直就像是背景里的存在。但我妈妈真的很了不起，因为她从不让这成为我们生活中的重大负担。她太棒了。她一边工作，一边经营自己的公司。所以她坚持完成了所有的治疗。这始终只是一个在背景中发生的事情，并没有对我们产生太大的影响。我想我们对她正在接受的治疗一直非常乐观，但遗憾的是，一年前她确实被诊断为晚期。她得了脑瘤，无法治疗。我们大约在
April, May time. So it gave her about three and a half months left. So it was, you know, the most challenging thing I think I'll ever go through. she was just incredible her kind of motto and something she shouted from the rooftop was every day's a gift so she had her own um company let's reset which was all about putting well-being and center of businesses that um I set up with her a few years ago kind of in lockdown um so she kept on talking about that until the very very end um so it's yeah it's very very special and becoming a clinical psychologist was something we always spoke about i mean when i started studying my undergrad she started referring to me as a clinical psychologist and i was like mum I'm not one yet stop telling your friends and colleagues I am one because I'm really not but I think um she's manifesting for me and we've got
4月到5月左右知道了这个消息。所以这给她留下了大约三四个月的时间。所以，你知道，这是我认为我经历过的最具挑战性的事情。她真的太不可思议了。她的座右铭以及她一直在大声疾呼的一句话是：“每一天都是一份礼物”。她有自己的公司——Let's Reset，这家公司致力于将健康置于企业中心。这是我和她几年前在封城期间一起创立的……所以她一直谈论这个话题，直到生命的最后一刻。所以，是的，这非常非常特别。成为一名临床心理学家是我们一直在谈论的事情。我的意思是，当我开始读本科时，她就开始称我为临床心理学家，而我说：“妈妈，我还不是呢，别再告诉你的朋友和同事我是了，因为我真的不是。”但我想，
there in the end but yeah third third year trying but I really do feel like it's the right time and last year it would have been a very very challenging year this year if I had got a place. So sorry to hear about the loss of your mum you know having lost my dad I know what a derailing process that is but also you're younger than me as well and so you you know you hope and expect to to hold on to your parents for a little bit longer and it might be timely to to mention a charity that I mentioned recently but they can never get enough mentions, really. So if anybody listening to this has lost a parent, you know, younger than 30, basically, do check out the charity called It's Time. I think on Instagram that It's Time charity.
她在为我显化这个愿望，我们最终还是做到了。但这是我第三次尝试，我真的觉得这是对的时机。如果去年我拿到了名额，那对今年来说将会是非常非常具有挑战性的一年。听到你失去母亲的消息我很难过，你知道，在失去了我父亲之后，我知道那是一个多么让人生活脱轨的过程。而且你也比我年轻，所以你知道，你原本希望并期待能多陪伴父母一段时间。现在也许是顺便提及一个慈善机构的好时机，我最近提到过它，但它怎么宣传都不嫌多。所以如果任何收听这节目的人失去了父母，基本上是在30岁之前，请务必去看看这个名为 It's Time 的慈善机构。我想在 Instagram 上是 It's Time charity。
But if you're watching on YouTube, there will be details in the on screen and if in your listening it will be in the show notes but it's very unique to lose a parent so young and it does affect us and especially you know given that you had a long journey with her illness as well that that shapes us and leaves its impact on your childhood and your young young adulthood in a way that is is just if you haven't had those difficulties others you know perhaps don't realize what it's like to have had that so sending you my deepest condolences your mum does sound like an incredible soul um and you know I've listened to one of her podcast episodes that you were in and she's just, you know, she's just got just a wonderful, had a wonderful spirit, a real energy about her. Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. She's just, yeah, lit up every room. talking today really is, I remember when shortly after my dad died, and I was looking at
但如果你是在 YouTube 上观看，屏幕上会有详细信息；如果你是在收听音频，它会出现在节目简介中。年纪轻轻就失去父母是相当独特的经历，这确实会影响我们。尤其是考虑到你陪伴她经历了漫长的病程，这塑造了我们，并在某种程度上对你的童年和年轻成年期产生了影响——如果你没有经历过这些困难，其他人可能不会真正理解那是什么感觉。所以我向你致以最深切的哀悼。你妈妈听起来确实是一个不可思议的灵魂，而且你知道，我听过你参与的那期她的播客节目，她真的有一种美妙的精神，身上有一种真正的活力。是的，是的，绝对的。她真的，是的，点亮了每一个房间。我们今天谈话的起因其实是，我记得在我父亲去世后不久，我正考虑
doing some training in EMDR. And I was told, you know, maybe it's not the right time for you, you know, with all of that stuff. And you know, with your young child who's not sleeping, and it's obviously a really tricky time, and you're juggling a lot of things um and I kind of mentioned oh I'm going to give it a miss this year to my um to my friend and colleague who um we trained at the same time we were assistants at the same time but we were on different courses and she was like what it's totally not the wrong time you're gonna going to love this and it's going to help energize you and it's going to help give you your why and give you your purpose. She was like, definitely, definitely do it. Like, I think this is going to be great for you.
去接受 EMDR（眼动脱敏再处理）的培训。当时有人对我说，你知道的，鉴于所有这些事情，这可能不是你的好时机。你知道的，还有一个不睡觉的小孩，这显然是一个非常棘手的时期，你要兼顾很多事情。然后我随口对我的朋友兼同事说：“我今年要放弃这个培训了。”我们是同一时期培训的，我们曾经同时担任助理，但在不同的课程上。她说：“什么？这绝对不是错误的时期。你会爱上它的，它会帮你重新注入活力，帮你找到你的“为什么”（why），并赋予你目标。”她当时说：“一定要去，绝对要去。我觉得这会对你很有帮助。”
And actually, she was right. She was right. And actually, I don't think I would have had the confidence to start my business if I didn't have like a specialty or like a thing. Like,'t even think you need a thing and often we don't need to think we're enough as we are and maybe I never needed the thing but I feel like having done the EMDR that I felt validated enough as well as the doctorate and the masters and the undergrad you know and the years of clinical practice I needed an extra thing to
事实上，她是对的。她是对的。而且实际上，如果我当时没有一个专长或者某种“核心技能”，我可能没有信心去创业。而且，我甚至觉得你根本不需要有什么“核心技能”，通常我们不需要觉得自己现在这样还不够好。也许我根本不需要那个技能。但我觉得做完 EMDR 后，再加上博士学位、硕士学位、本科经历（你知道的）以及多年的临床实践，我感觉自己得到了足够的认可，我需要多一样东西，
feel like I was offering value for money. So I also, that was a very long story, Jazz, but I'm delighted that I did what I did when I did it. And, you know, it was tricky. And I did end up crying during my training, because what we know, and what you should be prepared for is that often all roads lead to grief. So if you're doing any sort of therapy practice, you know, you only need to pull a small thread and then and then you'll get there but it's okay you know to be emotional I guess we don't want you crying in sessions with clients necessarily but I think we do some important healing whilst we're trying to learn how to heal others too. So tell me what that evokes for you.
来让自己觉得物有所值。所以这也是——这是一个很长的故事，爵士，但我很高兴我在当时做了我所做的事。而且，你知道，这确实很棘手。我在培训期间确实哭过，因为我们所知道的，以及你应该做好准备的是，通常所有的道路都会通向悲伤。所以如果你在做任何形式的治疗实践，你知道的，你只需要拉动一根小线头，然后——然后你就会到达那里。但没关系，你知道的，情绪化是可以理解的。我想我们不一定非要在与客户的治疗中哭泣，但我认为，在学习如何治愈他人的同时，我们也进行了一些重要的自我疗愈。所以，告诉我，这勾起了你怎样的回忆？
Tell me, had people said to you, maybe, you know, maybe grieve for a year, get on with training next year, you know, maybe this isn't your time or the opposite. What was your experience? Yeah, it's really interesting you were saying about your friend saying, go and do it. Because I had a similar situation. I think I was the one because as I said, mum died in the end of July, and obviously applications start in September. So by the time it came round, I was thinking, there's no way I'm applying this year. How am I possibly going to apply how you know how am I going to cope
告诉我，以前有人对你说过吗，比如：“也许应该悲伤一年，明年再继续培训，也许现在不是你的时机”或者正好相反？你的经历是怎样的？是的，这很有趣，你刚才说你的朋友叫你去参加。因为我也遇到了类似的情况。我想我当时是那个——因为正如我所说，妈妈在7月底去世了，而申请工作显然在9月份就开始了。所以当时间到来时，我在想：“我绝对不可能今年申请。我怎么可能申请？你知道的，我怎么应付得来？”
and I met an incredible lady by chance absolutely by chance who actually works in the BBC and I was thinking you know what I'm going to go into TV I'm going to leave psychology maybe it's not for me and you know with everything that's happened maybe I won't be able to cope essentially and I had an amazing dinner with her where she was very kind and generous with her time and talking about the work she did and asked me about what I did and kind of what previously I wanted to do and she just just said, yes, when you talk about psychology, and even the declines, your face lights up, you're so passionate about it. You need to keep going. And although it feels like right now is in the right time, I'd obviously told her the process
然后我机缘巧合下遇到了一位了不起的女士，绝对是机缘巧合。她其实在英国广播公司（BBC）工作。当时我在想，你知道吗，我要转行去电视圈，我要离开心理学，也许这不适合我。而且发生了这么多事，基本上我可能应付不过来。我和她共进了一次美妙的晚餐，她对她的时间和非常善良慷慨，谈论了她所做的工作，并问我从事什么工作以及我以前想做什么。她只是说：“是的，当你谈论心理学时，甚至在谈到拒绝时，你的脸上都在发光，你对它充满了热情。你需要继续坚持下去。”尽管感觉现在似乎不是好时机——我当时显然告诉了她整个流程。
of it. She goes, Jess, you don't know how you're going to feel in six months time by the time the interviews come up. And you don't know how you're going to feel in six months time by the time the interviews come up and you don't know how you're going to feel in a year's time I can assure you it's probably going to be better than you're feeling right now and it she was spot on she was spot on so I as I mentioned this was my third year applying and previous years I was starting those applications in September I was doing the reading doing you, all the preparation that you can for the application. And by the time I started my application this time, it was the end of October. Obviously, I'd had previous drafts,
她说：“杰丝，你不知道到六个月后面试到来时你会有什么感觉，你也不知道到六个月后面试到来时你会有什么感觉，你也不知道到一年后你会有什么感觉。我向你保证，那时的感觉很可能会比你现在感觉好得多。”而她完全说中了，完全说中了。所以，正如我所提到的，这是我第三年申请。前几年我都是在9月份开始准备那些申请材料，做阅读，做所有你能为申请做的准备。而这次当我开始准备申请时，已经是10月底了。显然我以前有写过草稿，
but I think I kind of took the pressure off myself and thought, I don't know how I'm going to feel in six months. What's meant to be will be. and I think I actually wrote the best application I've ever written because I took that pressure away and I thought you know what it's not meant to be then we'll we'll think about other things um and she was so spot on because by the time it came to my interviews, it had been over six months and mum had died. And I just felt stronger in myself, more resilient. My work had been fantastic. So I had a really good phased return to work.
但我认为我稍微卸下了自己的压力，心想：“我不知道六个月后我会是什么感觉。船到桥头自然直。”我想我实际上写出了我写过的最好的申请信，因为我卸下了那个压力，心想：“你知道吗，如果命中注定没有缘分，那我们就考虑别的事情吧。”她真的太准了。因为当面试来临时，已经过去六个月多一点了，妈妈也已经去世了。我感觉自己在内心变得更坚强、更有韧性了。我的工作表现一直很棒。所以我有一个非常顺利的、分阶段的重返工作岗位过程。
I'd got back into clinical work. I supervised. So, you know, with supervising, you can't screen out different cases. There were, you know, bereavement cases, cancer cases. I had to speak to a client who had gone through a similar situation as me. So I kind of felt, actually, I can do this. And yeah, by the time the interviews came out, it really did feel like the right time. And here we are. And I think it's one of those things that i know you know in a few weeks
我已经重新回到了临床工作。我还担任督导。所以，你知道，在做督导时，你是无法过滤掉不同病例的。其中有（你知道的）丧亲病例、癌症病例。我不得不与一个经历过和我类似情况的客户交谈。所以我当时有一种感觉：“实际上，我可以做到这一点。”是的，当面试结果出来时，真的感觉时机对了。我们现在就在这里。我想这是那种我知道你心知肚明的事情——再过几周，
when it's the anniversary that will be another challenging time i've got a summer now to kind of breathe reset but also kind of do some of my own processing and then hopefully by september i'll feel stronger still and you know be able to go through the waves of grief because that's exactly what grief is it goes in waves and comes up at yeah different times yeah and sometimes we will stand closer to that grief and at other times we'll feel a bit further away from it so we recently had father's day which i think was my fifth one without my dad and I just you know it's tricky because I miss him but he's not getting any more dead you know do you know what I mean does that sound really crass it's it's I've sort of accepted it now and knocked enough of the lumps off the trauma that it's just a level of sadness
当周年忌日到来时，那将是又一个充满挑战的时刻。现在我有一个夏天的时间来喘口气、重置一下，同时也进行一些我自己的心理消化。然后希望到了9月份，我会感觉更强大一些，并能够经历悲伤的波浪，因为这正是悲伤的本质——它一波接一波地袭来，在不同的时间点涌现。是的，有时候我们会离那种悲伤更近一些，而有时候我们会觉得离它远一些。所以我们最近过了父亲节，我想那是我没有爸爸陪过的第五个父亲节了。我只是，你知道的，这很棘手，因为我很想念他，但他不会变得更“死”了，你知道我的意思吗？你知道我在说什么吗？这听起来是不是很粗俗？我差不多已经接受了它，并且把创伤的棱角磨掉了一些，所以它现在只是一种恒定的悲伤水平。
that is always I'm getting upset now but always the same volume yeah yeah yeah unless I really connect to it like I am now and that's okay you know yeah it's okay and you know it will be six years in December yeah I think that's gonna cry today but you know I think almost if you're thinking oh well I'll apply for training now like my I don't know like I was thinking so I was um friends and supported a first year trainee when I was still in the NHS and actually her parent um died I think just as she just as she was starting training um might have been literally right at the start of training and that was so hard to try and meet people form part of a cohort when you were in acute grief and then trying to get all your work together and get your assignments done and really really tricky and actually one of the
我现在开始难过了，但它的分量总是那么大，是的，是的。除非我真的去触碰它，就像我现在这样。没关系，你知道的，是的，这没关系的。你知道，到今年12月就满六年了。是的，我想我今天又要哭了。但你知道，几乎就像是如果你在想：“哦，好吧，我现在要申请培训了，”就像我一样。不知道为什么，当我还在 NHS 工作时，我曾支持并结识了一位第一年的实习生。实际上她的父母去世了——我想就在她刚开始培训的时候，可能字面意义上就在培训刚开始的那几天。在处于急性悲伤期的时候，还要去试着结识新朋友、融入一个同伴群体，同时还要搞定所有的工作、完成作业，这真的非常非常棘手。实际上，有一个事情我发现拥有一个重病父母最具挑战性的是——害怕错过。你知道，我会错过那个时刻。而我几乎——我很幸运，我能够陪伴在那里，当我在的时候我也希望能在那里。我几乎像是从可能发生的最糟糕的事情中解脱出来了。对我来说，就是错过了那个时刻。你知道我的意思吗？
things I found most challenging about having a very unwell parent was fear that I would miss it you know I'd miss the moment and I'm almost you know I was fortunate I was able to be there and I wanted to be there when I was but I'm almost like freed from the worst thing that could happen like for me like missing it do you know what I mean yeah no and I can really relate to that and I think you know last summer I was able to take off time to be with mum and you know I was right there and oh gosh we're both getting each other going now but you know there I have that comfort that I couldn't have done anything more and for those couple of months I was able to just think about her do all the things that you know you want to do in those past months and you know
是的，不，我真的能感同身受。而且我认为，去年夏天我能够请假去陪伴妈妈，你知道的，我就在那儿。哦天哪，我们俩现在都要把对方弄哭了。但你知道，我有一种安慰，那就是我没有错过任何事，并且在那几个月里，我能够只想着她，做所有你知道在那些最后的日子里你想做的事情。而且你知道，她非常乐观，所以我们有很多笑声，我们非常幸运，因为我们在康沃尔海滩旁有一个美丽的地方，所以我们每天都能看到大海，太壮观了。我想就在我拥有——我想差不多就是我们发现她是癌症晚期的那一周，你知道，这些事情总是在美好的时刻发生——我收到了另一所大学临床心理学博士项目的拒信。这感觉太苦乐参半了，因为我在想：“从某种意义上说，谢天谢地。”但同样地，每一次拒绝都不会让痛苦减少，每一次拒绝都真的非常非常痛。但我认为，如果她——我不知道如果当时没有发生那些事，或者如果她还在受苦，我现在会在哪里。她太了不起了。事实上，她病得非常非常严重的急性期，从整个人生计划来看其实很短。你知道，去年1月她还和我80岁了不起的奶奶一起去了加拉帕戈斯群岛。所以在1月到5月期间，她不可思议地健康、硬朗。所以我感到非常幸运。而且我认为这个过程和这次培训只会让我感觉——我想——离她更近，因为我知道她多么希望我能做到这一点。
she was so positive so we had so much laughter and we were so lucky because we have a beautiful place by the beach in Cornwall so we could see the sea every day it was stunning and I think just just before I had um I think it was almost like the week we found out she was terminal you know these things happen at lovely times um I had got my rejection from another de-clinic at uni and it was so you know it was so bittersweet because I was thinking you know thank goodness in a way but equally it doesn't hurt less every rejection really really hurts but I think you know if she I don't know where I'd be right now if what had happened hadn't happened or if she was still suffering she was amazing that actually the acute period of her being really really poorly was actually in the scheme of things quite short you know she went to the
（注：原文此处有重复的口播内容，按规则原样保留翻译）
Galapagos with my amazing 80 year old granny last january so between january and may she was incredible and well and fit so you know i feel so lucky and i think this process and this training will only make me feel kind of i guess closer to her because I know how much she wants it for me. Yeah. Oh, thank you for being so authentic and sharing that with us. And we're both a bit of a mess today, but perhaps we're always going to be, Jazz, and that's okay. You know, we're humans. I do think I'm a better psychologist for what I've been through do you think that this has affected you as a human and a psychologist oh absolutely absolutely and just even getting the experience of being on the other side my mum had an amazing clinical psychologist
噢，谢谢你表现得如此真实并与我们分享这些。今天我们俩都把场面搞得一团糟，但也许我们注定总是会这样，爵士，这没关系。你知道，我们是人。我确实认为，经历过这些之后，我成了一名更好的心理学家。你认为这作为一个人和一个心理学家对你产生了影响吗？哦，绝对的，绝对的。仅仅是获得了作为“另一端家属”的体验——我妈妈的姑息治疗团队里有一位了不起的临床心理学家，她简直不可思议。我们在治疗过程中都在场，因为妈妈总是担心自己的身体会如何对情绪做出反应。但仅仅是获得了对临床心理学家所做工作的洞察，而且，你知道，我以前从未真正接触过临终关怀医院（hospice），我曾有过很多不准确的预期。我以为那会是非常令人沮丧、可怕、人们去那里等死的地方。而实际上那是最——同样是在康沃尔，那是见过的最美丽的临终关怀院。他们总是那么积极。这真的是关于——（注：原文此处有重复口误，按规则原样保留）
from her palliative team and she was just incredible and we actually I was there in the sessions because mum was always you know worried how her body would kind of respond to emotion but just having that insight into some of the work clinical psychologists do and you know I'd never really had experiences of hospices before and I had so many kind of expectations that it just wasn't accurate. I thought they were going to be really kind of depressing and horrible places that people go to die. When it was the most, again, it was in Cornwall. It's the most beautiful hospice ever. They were so positive all the time. And it was really aboutwall it's the most beautiful hospice ever they were so positive all the time
这真的是关于让妈妈尽可能舒适、快乐、尽可能能够做各种事情。所以这确实让我对生活的某个部分有了深刻的洞察——正如你所说，对某些人来说这是不可避免的。如果不是这样，我不会有这种经历。我认为，能够——我想我们所有人进入这个职业都是因为我们富有同情心、富有同理心，但当你经历了自身的挑战时，你可以用一种略微不同的方式产生共鸣。然后这就成了如何保持平衡的问题，你知道的，会有像现在这样的时刻，你在——你知道的，我在深深地思考、反思。所以当然我会情绪化，但这是一个了不起的机制——
and it was really about making mum as comfortable and happy and able to do things as possible so it's really given me insight into a part of I guess life that as you said is inevitable for some that I wouldn't have had and I think just being able to I think we all go into this profession because we are compassionate we are empathetic but when you go through your own challenges you can relate in a slightly different way um and then it's about just having a balance you know there's moments like now where you're you know I'm really thinking about it, reflecting. So of course I'm gonna get emotional, but there's an amazing,
我们的大脑简直太棒了，不是吗？它们可以进行心理隔离，你可以戴上工作、政治的帽子，让自己更加抽离。我想我有时会发现自己触景生情，然后心想：“哦，我能与此产生共鸣，”接着我能克制住自己。我认为重要的是，要拥有像今天这样的时刻，并与他人建立连接。再次感谢你分享你的经历。我想这可能就是为什么我更加情绪化。
our brains are just so fantastic, aren't they? They can compartmentalize and you can kind of have a work, political head on where you can separate yourself more. And I think I find myself sometimes it touching and I think, oh, I can relate to this, that I'm able to hold myself back. And I think it's important to then have moments like today and connecting with others. And again, thank you for sharing your experiences. I think that's probably why I'm more emotional.
就像，你知道的，你与其他人建立连接，拥有那种能够这样做的共和时间和空间。是的，我附和你所说的话。你知道，我曾经以为临终关怀院会是阴暗、凄凉、充满那些厌恶自己工作的痛苦之人的地方。事实并非如此。人们选择在那里工作是因为他们热爱他们所做的事。字面意义上，他们为尊严、尊重和同情心而活。你知道，他们是特别特别的人。我在父亲去世后整理的散文集《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective）中谈到过——我在实际面对客户时也会想到这一点——一个叫做“虾仁三明治时刻”（prawn sandwich moments）的概念。
Like, you know, you connect to other people that there's that time and space to be able to do so. Yeah, and I echo what you said. You know, I thought hospices were going to be bleak and gloomy and full of miserable people that hated their job. It's not. People choose to work there because they adore what they do literally they live for dignity and respect and compassion you know special special people you know and I I spoke in the book the grief collective which I put together after my dad died about um and I think about it with clients actually something called prawn sandwich moments
我不知道你是否熟悉我谈论这个。但即使在我们最黑暗的时刻——所以当你未来继续和人们一起处理创伤时——有时我们只关注可怕的事情（你知道，我们对所发生事情的画面以及它是多么可怕的记忆），但我们忘记了，也许在这个过程中，其实也有感到安慰的时刻。你知道，也许有人给我们带了一杯饮料，或者在我的例子中，我去了咖啡馆。我爸爸曾说：“请不要留我一个人，”所以我向他许下承诺：“你不会孤单的，总会有人陪着你。”所以我们有点像是在进行接力。但我去了咖啡馆，买了一个法式长棍面包，把它带了回来，坐在床头。这感觉也有点奇怪，因为他当时已经只能通过鼻饲管进食了，但他说：“菲利·布茨”（filly boots，口误），
i don't know if you're familiar with me talking about that but even in our darkest times so as you go on to process traumas with people in the future sometimes we just pay attention to the awfulness you know the images that we've got of what happened and how awful it was but we forget that maybe during that there were actually moments of comfort you know maybe somebody brought us a drink or in my case I went to the cafe so my dad had said please don't leave me by myself so I made a pledge to him that you won't be by yourself someone will always be with you so we kind of had a bit of a relay going but I went to the cafe and bought a baguette and brought it back and sat by the bedside which also feels a bit weird because he was nail by mouth by then like but he was like filly boots
然后我吃了我一生中吃过的最好吃的虾仁长棍面包——太美味了！我一边坐在他的床头，一边真的很享受食物，尽管情况很糟糕。但正是这些时刻，即使在一些非常痛苦的事情发生时——也许有人给你一个拥抱，也许你随身带着装在你最喜欢的茶水瓶里的热茶，你可以拥有这样的时刻：实际上你在放松、在自我抚慰、在寻求安慰，或者你允许自己被别人安慰。即使在发生了非常可怕的事情之后，当我们开始与经历过创伤的人交谈时——甚至在面对别人的加害时——当他们能够重新连接到那些舒适的“虾仁三明治时刻”，或者那些事情其实没有那么糟糕、其实很平静、很安静、可预测且可控的时刻时，这真的有助于加上标点符号。
um and I had the tastiest prawn baguette of my life like so nice and like I was really enjoying the food whilst sitting by his bedside and it being awful but it's those moments actually even during something really harrowing you know perhaps someone gives you a hug or perhaps you know you have brought your favourite tea
否则，那些感觉只是一团乱麻、巨大混乱的汤水般的事情，就会变得清晰。这有道理吗？噢，我太赞同了。正如我所提到的，妈妈的座右铭是“每一天都是一份礼物”，我们会不断地、有意识地谈论一天中最好的事情，我们会只谈论所有美好的事情。我想，你听说过“每天一秒钟”（one second a day）吗？这是一个应用程序，你可以记录每天的一秒钟视频。我一直在做这个——其实我是在第一次封城前、新冠疫情开始的那一年开始的，因为我想：“这将会是有史以来最好的一年，我要做所有这些——”
in a hot flask with you and you can have moments where actually you're decompressed and you're self-soothing or you're comforted or you allow yourself to be comforted by someone else and even in really horrendous things that have happened when we begin to to speak with the person who's experienced the trauma even at the hands of someone else when they're able to connect to those prawn sandwich moments of of comfort or where it just wasn't so bad where it
事情。然后很显然我们被封城了。但实际上我坚持做“每天一秒钟”，我回看它的时候，显然我们都记得封城是什么样的，被限制不能做很多事情。但我的“每天一秒钟”视频看起来老实说就像我过了一生中最美好的一年。事后回想起来，这甚至更加特别，因为我和妈妈在一起。因为我们在康沃尔，因为我在工作，我在康沃尔接受 PWP（心理安康从业者）培训，所以我们有大海，我们有——我在康沃尔接受 PWP 培训，所以我们有大海，我们还度过了最美妙的夏天。所以字面意义上每天都在海边，每天都和妈妈在一起，我们吃着好吃的食物。我想正是那种——那个视频确实把这些美好刻在了我脑海里。即使在充满挑战的时期，每天也总有美好的时刻。而且我相信，我和妈妈在一起的时光也是如此。
was actually calm and quiet and predictable and controllable that really helps to to put punctuation in so otherwise what feels like a just a big mess big soup flood of of chaos does that make sense oh I so agree and as I mentioned mum's little thing was every day's a gift and she we would constantly consciously talk about the best things in the day and see we would just talk about all the all the good things and i think have you have you heard of kind of one second a day it's an app where you take kind of a one second of every day and i've been doing it for i started it actually before the first lockdown as covid started that year because i thought oh this is going to be the best year ever and i'm going to do all these
当然，夏天那几个月非常具有挑战性，但也有非常美好的时刻。我们的“虾仁三明治”是一只螃蟹三明治，那是我的——我的虾仁三明治平替版。那是最神奇的——我记得它。因为妈妈最大的优点是她直到最后还能吃东西，我认为这——这简直是最好的事情，因为她热爱美食。所以我们吃了很多好吃的食物，反思这一点总是一件好事，这很重要。我爸爸死于食管癌，所以在去世前很长一段时间，进食对他来说是个问题。但你的螃蟹三明治听起来太棒了。而且，你知道的，我们在“毒性积极性”（gaslighting）和正能量之间在哪里划清界限呢？
things and then obviously we were locked in but actually i continued the one second a day and i looked back on it and obviously we remember what lockdown was like and being you know not a restricted on doing so many things but my one second a day video looks like honestly that I had the best year of my life and in hindsight it's even more special because I was with mum but because we were in Cornwall for it because I was working I was doing my PWP training in Cornwall so we had the sea we had, I was doing my PWP training in Cornwall, so we had the sea, we had the most amazing summer as well, so literally by the sea every day, I'm with mum every day, we were eating good food, and I think it is that, that video really hones that into me back then, but actually even at a time that is challenging, there are always
当客户面对悲剧和悲伤时依然表现得 relentlessly positive（无情地积极）时，你知道，有时我会想：“去看看那些悲伤的碎片其实是安全的。”你知道，我绝对看到了寻找快乐的价值。但实际上有些时候，我昨天度过了糟糕透顶的一天。我临床工作中的其中一天，真的、真的很垃圾，糟糕透顶，你知道的。有些事情是无法通过重新构架来解决的。你知道，我小儿子给了我一个拥抱，我丈夫把孩子们哄睡了。但这只是在给垃圾般的现实垫上垫子，不是吗？你知道，至少每个人对我都不是很尖酸刻薄，也没有向我扔西红柿。
good moments in every day, and I believe that also with my time with mum you know obviously it was a really challenging few months in summer but there were really good moments and ours was a crab sandwich that was my my my prawn sandwich equivalent um the most amazing tip I remember it and because the great thing about mum is she could eat till the end which I think well it's the best thing ever because she loved her food so we ate a lot of good food and it's always a good thing to reflect that is important so my dad died of esophageal cancer, so eating was problematic for quite a while before he died. But your crab sandwich sounds amazing. And, yeah, you know, where do we draw the line between, you know, gaslighting and positivity, you know?
而且，你知道，他们没有全都离家出走——情况本可能会更糟。但只是，你知道的，我在专业和信心上受到了打击，这确实产生了影响。我们不能只是把鞋子擦得锃亮，然后心想：“哦，一切都很好，一切都很好，”因为有时情况确实不好，我们必须尊重真实的感受，不是吗？是的，是的。而且我认为，特别是当你经历创伤性情境时，你不能只是死死抓住所有的积极面并反思所有伟大的事情，因为现实是，这真的很难。有些元素是创伤性的。我认为，你知道，悲伤就是一个很好的例子，你知道的，它不会离开我们。正如你所说，我们——关于悲伤的世界变大了，但悲伤的规模和痛苦依然如故。
And when clients are, like, relentlessly positive, even in the face of tragedy and sadness, you know, sometimes I'm like, it's safe to look at the sad bits a little bit. You know, I absolutely see the value for finding joy. But actually some days, I had a really shit day yesterday. One of my days clinically, really, really rubbish, awful, you know. And there's not really any reframing around that some days. You know, my little boy gave me a hug and my husband put the kids to bed. But this is just cushioning the rubbishness, isn't it? You know, at least everyone wasn't mean to me and didn't throw tomatoes at me.
这只是需要记住它是一波接一波的。我想我所寻求的安慰——我想这确实是一个积极的立场：如果我今天过得不好，我允许自己过糟糕的一天。如果我很想念妈妈，我允许自己去想念。尤其是，我知道一年中的这个时候，距离周年忌日还有一个月，我会有更多摇摆不定的日子和这样的时刻。但我知道它会过去。我知道会有那种感觉不再那么巨大、不再那么吞噬一切的时刻。我想这就是我得到的安慰：我可以放任自己，我几乎可以把这一天“写掉”，心想：“好吧，今天不是我能以同样的方式完成任务的日子，但明天可能会好一点。”如果明天还是不行，它最终也会过去的。
And, you know, they didn't all move out you know it could have been could have been worse but just you know I was knocked professionally and confidently and that has its impact and it's not okay to kind of shine up our shoes and and think oh it's all fine you know it's all fine because sometimes it isn't and we have to honor our truths don't't we? Yeah, yeah. And I think, you know, especially when you're going through a traumatic situation, you can't just, you know, hold on to all the positives and reflect on all the great things, because the reality is, it is really hard. And there are elements that are traumatic. And I think, you know, grief is a brilliant example of that, that, you know, it doesn't leave us. As you said, there are, you know, our world a brilliant example of that, that, you know, it doesn't leave us. As you said, there are, you know, our world around grief gets bigger, but the size and the pain of the grief stays the same.
绝对的。有时候，有些人会说，其实一周中的某一天对他们来说更有感触。例如，如果他们的挚爱死于星期六、星期日或星期二，那么每周的那一天会让他们觉得联系最紧密，因为它有一种相似的节奏。而如果他们死于星期四，但他们的忌日落在——我不知道——星期日，这一天的节奏就会非常不同，如果这讲得通的话。但为了以防有用，我从不工作度过我爸爸的忌日。
And it's just remembering that it goes in ways. And I think what I take comfort on, and I guess it is a positive stance, but I let myself, if I'm having a bad day, I let myself have a bad day. If I'm really missing mum, I let myself. And especially, I know this time of year, it's a month till the anniversary, I'm going to have more wobbly days and moments like this. But I know that it will pass. And I know that there will be times where it doesn't feel as big
实际上，我只是试着把它变成一个正念日，我请一天的年假，只允许自己稍微难过一点，或者去做一些更有趣的事情，你知道的。实际上，在我爸爸的生日那天——虽然大流行确实有点妨碍了这一点，但他是在2017年12月去世的，而他的生日其实就在他去世前10天，这有点太糟糕了。但我哥哥、我和我妈妈在他去世后的第一个生日周年纪念日那天去跳伞了——室内跳伞！当时我妈妈已经70岁了，还有我哥哥，我当时大概36岁，可能已经37岁了，还有我哥哥（他比我大几岁）。你知道，我们所有人一起去做了那个。然后第二年——我爸爸其实是个锅炉工，他显然经常穿锅炉工连体裤或裤子。
and consuming and I think that's what I take comfort in that I can let myself I can almost write off the day and be like okay today's not not the day that I'm gonna get things done in the same way but tomorrow might be a bit better and if it isn't it will eventually pass and absolutely and sometimes um some people say that actually the day of the week is more evocative for them so for example if their loved one died on a saturday or sunday or tuesday it's actually that day in that week that feels most connected because it's got a similar rhythm whereas if you know if they died on a Thursday and their anniversary is on a I don't know a Sunday there's a very different rhythm to the day if that makes sense but you know in case it's useful I never work my dad's
非常随机地，第二年我们去开卡丁车了。所以连续两年在他的生日那天，我们都穿着锅炉工连体裤。我当时非常非常兴奋地想看看2020年会带来什么。然后当然，正如你所说的那样，我们看到了2020年带来了什么，我们实际上没有再做过任何锅炉工连体裤相关的活动。所以如果任何人有关于锅炉工连体裤活动的点子，可以让我哥哥、我妈妈和我一起做的，请告诉我。但是的，我想我为它留出了空间，这可能会是一些有用的事情。最终，也许我能够忍受在爸爸的生日或忌日那天工作，但也许我不必这样做，你知道，那也没关系。我想是的。而且我往往发现，真正的那些日子其实并没有那么糟糕，我认为是那段积累的预热期比较难熬。
anniversary um and actually I just try to make that a mindful day where I take a day's annual leave and just allow myself to be a bit sadder or to do something a bit more fun, you know. And actually on my dad's birthday, so the pandemic did rather get in the way of this, but he died in December 2017. And his birthday was actually 10 days before he died, which is just a bit rubbish you know um but my brother and me and my mum on his first birthday anniversary since he died we did we go we went skydiving like indoor skydiving so there's my mum who's 70 at the time my brother and I think I was 36 I might have been 37 by then um and my brother who's a couple of years older than me you know and we were all doing that together and then the next year so my dad was actually a boiler man and he um obviously often wore boiler suits or trousers
因为你预料到那会是非常艰难的一天，随着时间的推移，情况可能会有所不同。因为我认为有很多“第一次”，而且很多人告诉我：“熬过第一个周年就会很难。”我想类似地，在我妈妈的生日那天，我们去了剧院，去看了她最喜欢的演出《汉密尔顿》（Hamilton）。我去了下午茶，我的奶奶、我的阿姨、我哥哥都在那里。所以这非常特别。但第二天，我其实——我熬过了那天，因为她的生日在母亲节前两天，所以那是属于她的那一周。然后在那之后，熬过了母亲节，一切都还好，然后我就崩溃了。精疲力竭，情绪被榨干了。
and just randomly the next year we went go-karting so for two years in a row on his birthday we were all wearing boiler suits so I was really really excited to see what 2020 brought and then of course very much like you said we saw what 2020 brought and we actually haven't done any more boiler suit activities so if anyone's got any ideas of boiler suit activities that my brother and my mum and I could do um you know let me know but yeah I I guess I make space for that and that might be something that's useful and ultimately maybe I'll be able to bear to to work his birthday or his anniversary but maybe I don't have to you know and that's okay I think so and I tend to find that the actual days aren't actually that bad I think it's the build-up because you are
所以有时这是不可预测的，但我们只能顺其自然。而且正如你所说，在可能的时候做一些美好的事情来怀念我们爱的人——如果正好在忌日那天，那当然很好；如果不在，那也依然很好。拥有能够继续怀念他们、做一些美好有趣事情的时刻，我认为这真的很重要。是的，这在很大程度上说明了——你必须到达那个点：如果现在感觉太困难，最终我们必须到达那个点，即我们知道自己被允许过上美好、充实、享受的生活，我们被允许再次体验快乐，尽管那个人已经不在了，而这没有关系。我只是在想，如果有人在收听这期节目，并且正处于非常棘手的事情之中，
expecting it to be a really hard day and it may be different as the years go by because I think it's a lot of firsts and there's a lot of people that tell me you know get through the first and they're gonna be hard and I think similarly like my mum's birthday we went to the theatre we went and saw Hamilton which was her favourite show. I went to afternoon tea and my granny came, my auntie came, my brother was there. So it was really special. But the day after, I just actually, I got through it because her birthday was two days before Mother's Day, so it was the week of her. And then after that, got through Mother's Day, it was okay, and then just collapsed. So exhausted and like emotionally drained so
预料到这会是非常艰难的一天，而且随着时间的推移可能会有所不同，因为我觉得有很多“第一次”，很多人告诉我，你知道的，挺过第一个就会好起来的，虽然过程会很艰难。我觉得类似我妈妈的生日，我们去了剧院，去看了她最喜欢的演出《汉密尔顿》。我去吃了下午茶，我奶奶来了，我阿姨来了，我弟弟也在。所以这真的特别。但第二天，其实我……我撑过去了，因为她的生日在母亲节前两天，所以那是属于她的一个星期。然后在那之后，撑过了母亲节，还好，然后整个人就崩溃了。精疲力竭，情绪也彻底透支了，所以
sometimes it's unpredictable but we just have to go with the motions and I think as you said doing nice things to remember our loved ones when you can if it's on the anniversary then great but if it's not then that's still great just having moments to still you know remember them and do nice fun things I think it's really important yeah it's very much you know you have to get to the point where maybe if it feels too difficult now but ultimately we have to get to the point where we know that we're allowed to live a good full enjoyable life we're allowed to experience joy again even though that person's not there and that's okay. I'm just thinking if somebody's listening to this episode and they're in the middle of something very tricky right now,
有时这是无法预测的，但我们只能顺其自然。就像你说的，在你可以的时候做一些美好的事情来缅怀我们挚爱的人，如果在忌日那天固然很好，但如果不是也没关系，只要有那么几个时刻，你仍然可以去缅怀他们，做一些美好有趣的事情，我觉得这真的很重要。是的，很大程度上你知道，你必须达到这样一种程度：也许现在感觉太困难了，但归根结底，我们必须达到这样一种程度，即我们知道我们被允许过上美好、充实、愉快的生活，我们被允许再次体验快乐，即使那个人已经不在了，这也是可以的。我只是在想，如果有人在收听这一集节目，而他们现在正处于某个非常棘手的困境中，
what would happen if you were a trainee and the worst is happening? You know, actually it is still just a job. You can take a period of sick leave absence and I guess you'd speak to your placement supervisor about hopefully you'd have a good relationship you'd speak to your cohort you'd speak to your course tutor and you'd you'd come up with a plan really for what's going to help you get through what you're going through and what period of time you might need and ultimately it is just a job if you need to kind of defer for a few months or drop down to the next cohort next year have that conversation that's I guess what are your thoughts around that I think I think communication is so key and to be as open as you can and ask for help is you know it's it's hard but I think it
如果你是一名实习生，而最糟糕的情况发生了，会怎么样呢？你知道，其实它依然只是一份工作。你可以请一段病假，我想你会和你的实习督导交流——希望你们关系不错，你可以和你的同伴交流，和你的课程导师交流，然后你们会真正地共同制定一个计划，看什么能帮度过你正在经历的难关，你可能需要多长时间，归根结底，它只是一份工作，如果你需要推迟几个月，或者明年降级到下一届，去谈谈吧，我想你对此有什么看法？我认为，我认为沟通是如此关键，尽可能地保持坦诚并寻求帮助，你知道，这很难，但我觉得它
I can't stress how important it is my I've always been one of those people that has felt like work is the most important thing and I love it I love the work I do and I felt really guilty about taking time off work but I had an amazing supervisor who was like Jaz it's actually spending time with your mum is way more important than work it is just a job and it will be exactly where it is when you come back and when I came back again I actually changed supervisor my next one was like just as amazing and I was saying you know I'm back and I'm ready to jump back in and blah blah blah like a million miles per hour and she just paused me and she was like dad you don't need to jump back into it let's go gradual take it as it comes keep the
我怎么强调它的重要性都不为过。我一直都是那种觉得工作是最重要的人，我热爱它，我热爱我做的工作，而且我对请假感到非常内疚。但我有一位非常棒的督导，她说：“贾兹，其实花时间陪你妈妈比工作重要得多，这只是一份工作，当你回来时，它会原封不动地在那里。”当我回来时，我甚至换了督导，我的下一位督导也同样棒极了。我说：“你知道，我回来了，我已经准备好重新投入工作了，等等等等，像风风火火一样。”但她只是让我停下来，她说：“贾兹，你不需要马上投入进去，我们循序渐进，随遇而安，保持
communication open and I did I had a real phased return over a couple of months and it was the best thing because now I'm working at full capacity and have done since around Christmas time and I feel myself at work again I don't feel kind of on the edge or kind of like I'm having to battle things or put things to one side I just feel myself and I can imagine in training and I guess it is similar NHS settings we're so lucky in the NHS with the sick leave that they're able to support you with and a lot of services are really flexible that keep that communication open so they can support you through it and I'd hope that if it had happened during training that I'd be able to get that same support in a similar way and you know not not every journey is linear is it and at the end of the day you'll still graduate you'll still get that title if you want
沟通顺畅。”我照做了，在几个月的时间里，我真的经历了一个渐进式的复工过程，这是最棒的做法，因为现在我能以满负荷工作了，从圣诞节左右开始就一直是这样，我觉得自己在工作中又找回了自我，不再觉得自己如履薄冰，或者觉得必须与各种事情搏斗，或者把事情搁置一旁，我只觉得做回了自己。我可以想象，在培训中，我想这类似于NHS（国民保健署）的环境，我们在NHS真的很幸运，有病假支持，很多服务也非常灵活，保持沟通顺畅，这样他们就能在你经历难关时给予支持。我希望如果这件事发生在培训期间，我也能以类似的方式获得同样的全力支持，而且，你知道，并不是每段旅程都是呈直线发展的，对吧？到头来，如果你愿意，
it but it doesn't have to be in one go if you have something this big going on yeah absolutely and just you know yeah like you said ask ask for help people aren't mind readers and you don't need to put all this pressure on yourself to keep doing everything and juggling all the plates and I think you know I think it's a little bit different if we are not doing a clinical facing role because you can kind of be a bit more insular, but what you so nicely demonstrated when you were talking about supervision is that you're going to get stuff that's going to rub up against your raw wounds when you least expect it. So when I did my phased return,
你仍然会毕业，你仍然会获得那个头衔，但如果你遇到了这么大的事情，它不一定非要一气呵成。是的，完全如此，而且你知道，就像你说的，寻求帮助，人们不会读心术，你不需要给自己施加所有这些压力去坚持做每件事并同时应付各种事情。我觉得，如果我们从事的不是临床面对面的工作，情况可能会稍微不同一点，因为你可以更加封闭一些，但正如你在谈论督导时非常精彩地展示的那样，当你最意想不到的时候，你会遇到那些触及你未愈合伤口的事情。所以当我进行渐进式复工时，
we did try to avoid grief stuff, but then I ended up picking up a client with the same name, you know, the same name cropped up in like as being key to the story and I thought you just couldn't necessarily see that coming and you know the like you said there's death and illness and dying everywhere and even when you are trying to be a bit selective you will still get rubbed and you need to make sure that you aren't going to be a complete mess and you're still going to be helpful and not just kind of make it you know transfers cancer transfers all that good stuff but you know a good relationship with your supervisor is key isn't it absolutely
我们确实试图避开有关悲伤的事情，但后来我接手了一个同名的来访者，你知道，那个名字在故事中作为关键要素出现了，我想你无法完全预料到这一点。而且你知道，就像你说的，到处都有死亡、疾病和垂死，甚至当你试图有所选择时，你仍然会受到触动，你需要确保自己不会彻底崩溃，并且依然能够提供帮助，而不是把事情弄得一团糟，把创伤转嫁给来访者，诸如此类的好事情。但是，你知道，与督导建立良好的关系是关键，不是吗？绝对的，绝对的。
absolutely yeah no I had a call with a client who was really upset recently bereaved and he's like you just don't understand to me getting really upset and I'm there like I do but I can't say I do and it was really it was really challenging but again my supervisor was amazing and I think you know where you can be flexible and avoid those cases where you can is great especially in the early stages but it's also that understanding that we can't screen out everything and of course it will come out but it's important to think step back and reflect afterwards has that impacted me where am I feeling how am I fitting with it
是的，不，我最近和一位非常难过、刚刚经历丧亲之痛的来访者通过电话，他说：“你根本不理解。”他变得非常激动，而我在一旁想：“我理解，但我不能说我理解。”这真的非常具有挑战性。但同样，我的督导非常棒，我觉得在条件允许的情况下保持灵活并尽量避开这些案例是很好的，尤其是在早期阶段，但同时也要明白，我们不可能筛查掉所有事情，它当然会暴露出来，但重要的是在事后退一步并进行反思：这对我产生了什么影响？我在哪里有所感受？我目前是如何适应它的？
right now and how can I go forward yeah I mean I guess it depends on the placement and it depends on your style and it depends on what feels authentic to you. But I will, you know, often now these days say, oh, I'm really sorry to hear that. You know, I lost my dad too. So I kind of get some of what you're saying. And then you almost can take a breath and go, oh, right, OK. Right. You know, you almost levels the playing field and you know where you're at. Like you and I obviously have a lot in common. And so you feel like, you know, it deepens the work almost because you've got that context and that shared understanding but that said we don't need to have experienced the thing that someone has experienced to be able
以及我该如何继续前进？是的，我的意思是，我想这取决于实习机构，取决于你的风格，也取决于什么对你来说感觉是真实的。但现在我经常会说：“听到这个消息我真的很遗憾，你知道，我也失去了父亲，所以我有点理解你的部分感受。”然后你几乎可以喘口气说：“哦，对了，好的，好吧。”你知道，这几乎拉平了彼此的地位，让你知道自己的处境。就像你和我显然有很多共同点，所以你会觉得，你知道，这几乎加深了工作深度，因为你有这样的背景和共同的理解。话虽如此，我们不需要经历过别人经历过的事情才能在临床上帮助他们，
to clinically help them but it's a balance and it's what feels okay for you and what feels safe and and if you're in a dynamic service and obviously that's that's not what you're going to do you know we're going to very measured in our responses okay um is there anything we haven't spoken about that you think would be useful for somebody that's kind of mulling over all of this stuff i i think the only thing bring it it back to applications, I would just always say, just do it. The application process is such a long process. And as my amazing guardian angel Sue told me, you don't know how you're going to be feeling in six months time. So if you're going through something around that September period just
但这是一种平衡，什么对你来说感觉没问题，什么感觉安全，如果你在一个充满活力的服务机构中，显然那不是你要做的，你知道，我们在回应时会非常谨慎。好的，嗯，我们有没有什么还没聊到、你觉得对一个正在琢磨所有这些事情的人会有帮助的内容？我想唯一的一件事，把它拉回到申请上，我总是会说：直接去申请吧。申请过程是一个非常漫长的过程。正如我不可思议的守护天使苏告诉我的：“你不知道自己在六个月后会有什么感觉。”所以如果你在9月份左右经历着某些事情，那就
put the application through and wait and see you don't know what's going to happen take the pressure off yourself and have comfort in the experience you have and and you know what's meant to be will be we know amazing potential clinical psychologists don't get on because, you know, the demand and everything else. So I think don't take yourself out of the running because you don't feel ready in the moment. I also think that, you know, the first year, I'm so glad I applied. I wasn't anywhere near ready the first year I applied, but I wanted to
把申请交上去，然后拭目以待。你不知道会发生什么，卸下自己的压力，从你的经验中寻找慰藉，你知道，命中注定的终究会注定。我们知道许多极具潜力的临床心理学家没有被录取，因为，你知道，需求和其他种种原因。所以我觉得不要因为你觉得自己当下还没准备好就把自己排除在竞选之外。我也觉得，你知道，第一年，我太高兴我申请了。我第一年申请时离准备好还差得远，但我想要
get to know the process because it is quite a unique process. And again, it was a trial run. And actually, I ended up on a reserve list of my first year, because again, I think I took the pressure off. Second year, I put so much pressure on myself to get it. And then mum got ill in the middle of it. So that didn't work out so well and then this year again pressure was off but I felt ready and I think you get to know the process um and yeah just have confidence in yourself but also you know rejections are always going to be hard they're always going to hit they're always going to make you feel like you've failed even though you haven't um so you know be as everyone says and I know your previous episodes have said
了解这个流程，因为它是一个相当独特的流程。同样，那是一次试运行。事实上，第一年我最终进入了后备名单，因为同样，我觉得我卸下了压力。第二年，我给自己施加了太大的压力非要考上，结果中间妈妈生病了，所以事情并没有那么顺利。而今年，压力再次卸下了，但我感觉自己准备好了。我觉得你逐渐了解了这个流程，嗯，是的，对你自己有信心，但同时，你知道，拒绝总是很难的，它们总是会带来打击，它们总是会让你觉得自己失败了，尽管你并没有失败。所以，你知道，正如每个人所说的那样，而且我知道你之前的节目也说过，
you've said you know it's important to be kind to yourself and um protect your energy around it as well thank you that's such good advice um and I know that you've you kind of um slipped into my dms on um linkedin originally to say how much you've enjoyed the podcast and how it's been a really nice companion to you during this process so thanks for your kind words both today and before the podcast and once again I'm so sorry for the loss of your mum she sounds very special people want to listen to her podcast which is still running um where can they do that yeah on spotify is the best place to go um it's called let's reset the podcast and obviously the last episode is quite a triggering episode it was her last one and
你说过，你知道，对自己好一点是很重要的，并且也要保护好自己在这方面的能量。谢谢你，这真是太棒的建议了。嗯，我知道你最初是通过领英的私信找到我的，说你有多么喜欢这个播客，以及它在整个过程中如何成为你非常棒的伴侣，所以谢谢你今天以及在播客录制前对我的暖心话语。再次为你的母亲的离去感到遗憾，她听起来非常特别。人们如果想听她的播客，这个播客还在运营，他们可以在哪里收听？是的，在Spotify上收听是最好的选择，它叫做“让我们重置播客”（Let's Reset Podcast）。显然最后一集是非常容易勾起回忆的一集，那是她的最后一集，
she very much openly spoke about dying but also about her career in marketing and her most recent business let's reset but the whole key idea of it was talking to lots of different entrepreneurs CEOs people in business and talking about how their well-being impacts what they do so there's some brilliant brilliant speakers on it ran for about three years so there's about 50 episodes to listen to and yeah I'm sorry I never got a chance to talk with her but um you know I'm pleased I got a chance to speak with you um well done and wishing you all the very best for your training and beyond. And if you need anything, give me a shout. Thank you, Marianne.
她非常坦率地谈论了死亡，也谈到了她自己的市场营销职业生涯以及她最近的业务“让我们重置”（Let's Reset）。但其核心理念是与许多不同的企业家、首席执行官、商界人士进行对话，探讨他们的福祉如何影响他们所做的事情。所以上面有一些非常非常精彩的演讲者，节目做了大约三年，所以大约有50集可以收听。是的，很遗憾我从未有机会与她交谈，但是，你知道，我很很高兴有机会和你交谈。干得好，祝你的培训及未来一切顺利。如果你需要任何帮助，随时联系我。谢谢你，玛丽安。
It's been such a pleasure to be on the podcast. And yeah, I hope it helps, you know, one or two people going through similar challenges. I'm sure it will. I'm sure it will. Thank you so much for your time. Thank you. Oh, thank you so much to our guest, Jazz. What a very special episode that has been.
能来参加这个播客我感到非常荣幸。是的，我希望它能帮助一两个正在经历类似挑战的人。我相信会的，我相信会的。非常感谢你抽出时间。谢谢。哦，非常感谢我们的嘉宾贾兹。这真是一期非常特别的节目。
Thank you for listening all the way through and watching all the way through if you're on YouTube. I would love to know what you think to this. You can drop a comment on Spotify if you have got any thoughts. You can also drop a comment on YouTube where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I would love your feedback. Come and let me know on my socials, Dr. Marianne Trent. Come and join the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community.
感谢你一直听到最后，如果你在YouTube上，也感谢你一直看到最后。我很想知道你对此有何看法。如果你有任何想法，可以在Spotify上发表评论。你也可以在YouTube上发表评论，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我很期待听到你的反馈。快来我的社交媒体上告诉我吧，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。快来加入免费的Facebook群组：有志心理学家社区（The Aspiring Psychologist Community）。
You know, it feels like this podcast is doing such important things. What a privilege it is to do and to have such important, powerful, poignant conversations such as that that I had with Jazz. If you enjoy the support and the camaraderie of this podcast, imagine what it's like in the aspiring psychologist membership which you can join from just 30 pounds a month please do check out the books the aspiring psychologist collective and the clinical psychologist collective and with special relevance today the grief collective which is a unique collection of 54 stories related to people who've grieved not just for people who've died but things they've lost or people they've lost mostly it's people um yeah gets also wonderful reviews thank you so much please do subscribe please do follow the show do follow the show. That is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster if you value their content, is just to subscribe or follow the show. Thank you so much.
你知道，感觉这个播客正在做如此重要的事情。能够开展并进行像我和贾兹所进行的那样重要、有力、深刻的对话，是多么荣幸的一件事。如果你喜欢这个播客的支持和情谊，想象一下加入“有志心理学家会员计划”（aspiring psychologist membership）会是怎样的体验，你只需每月30英镑即可加入。请务必查看这些书籍：《有志心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）和《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），以及与今天特别相关的《悲伤集体》（The grief collective），这是一部由54个故事组成的独特合集，讲述了人们如何经历悲伤——不仅是为离世的人悲伤，也是为他们失去的事物或失去的人悲伤。大部分都是关于人的，嗯，是的，它也获得了非常精彩的评价。非常感谢，请务必订阅，请务必关注这个节目，关注这个节目。如果你珍视任何播客的内容，你能为他们做的最友善的事情就是订阅或关注这个节目。非常感谢。
If you've got any ideas for future episodes, please do let me know. Take care of yourself. Be kind to yourself. I'll look forward to bringing you the next episode of the podcast, which will be available from 10 a.m. on Saturday and from 6 a.m. on Mondays for the MP3, wherever you get your podcasts. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you to be on your way to being qualified
如果你对未来的节目有任何想法，请务必告诉我。照顾好自己。善待自己。我期待着为你带来下一期播客，它将于周六上午10点以及周一上午6点（MP3版本）上线，无论你在哪里收听播客都能找到它。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向获得资质的道路。
it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Trent my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的“有志心理学家播客”。我叫贾娜，我是一名实习心理福祉从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。它让我惊叹于通往这一目标的途径竟然有这么多，而且并没有成为心理学家的唯一完美方式。这让我充满了信心，让我知道我并没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下了。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。